hey guys welcome back to another
unboxing and today we have my good
friend here
total war warhammer 2 the serpent god
edition uh this collector's edition is
actually
loaded with a bunch of stuff um and it's
still available for pre-order on total
war's website
for 149 so we're going to go ahead
open this and i think this time i'll be
a little
more gentle
and first thing is the total war
warhammer 2 steelbook
this one does not doesn't have anything
in it but when you buy it
it certainly will oh so
leave that right there and let's dig
into this
huge box right here bring it over here
oh my goodness there is
a lot of good stuff in here i would
assume
oh box right there oh it already opened
up
so this thing looks to be oh my goodness
and so let's see what's inside this
we got a couple pages looks like it's a
nice little art book here uh it's the
first thing that you'll see when you
open this up
inside however it's a lot more
this is where i assume the uh steel book
goes right here
so we'll stick that in there
[Music]
perfect fit there's also a little
scroll do that
right there those gloves are a good idea
i know
right here it's a canvas map
nice look at what's behind here
so many layers i know okay
here's where got some good stuff
here is the uh puzzle sphere
it's a puzzle joey you're supposed to
turn it
oh you be careful okay okay so whoa
i say put that down we'll come back to
it oh
you're already doing it
so this is the stone effect puzzle
sphere uh we do have the solution uh we
do know how to crack this thing
um so we'll be doing that later just
make sure there will be spoilers
okay so let's take a look at this guy
right here all right and next up we have
the
saurus blade usb stick right here
comes with a bunch of black library
ebooks
so you can load that into your computer
get some reading done
is it kind of metal yeah it's a die-cast
metal
and then next up we have
oh this is the little stand for the uh
the puzzle sphere right here so we'll
put that up front right there we'll come
back to you
all right next up we have a little
lanyard right here and i believe this is
for the uh
things that are coming up next oh no i
guess not
i could have sworn there was more stuff
in here more foam
and that's it what there are no totems
unless ooh you know what
it's got to be in the sphere
oh my god okay looks like we are opening
this up right now
you're totally right okay it's happening
it's sphere time spoilers ahead
to open it you turn the top half of the
map facing up
okay uh you've already done this so it's
clockwise top half
clockwise and then you turn it
anti-clockwise
again okay and all the three uh little
points right here
popped up
[Music]
oh that wasn't very hard at all
the hard part
[Music]
well i'll get to that in a second inside
here though this little bag
are the little teeth totems
right there
so there will be a four total
[Music]
there
and so on on the base of each one of
these has a little hole that you can uh
string that lanyard through so you can
wear them just like that
okay i'm gonna see if i can find it in
here maybe
a lanyard
oh just instructions i can learn how to
tie a cool knot though
maybe i should try that
[Music]
i'm going to string together this guy
looks cool
well this is two slipknots it's a double
[Music]
um right
just gonna have a little home around my
neck okay so you said
closing this is the difficult part right
now
why don't we let you try give it a go
see if you can
easy first step to closing two hollow
circles
on the equator are they lined up yes
they are
find the first pin by following the
spine of sotech mountains
[Music]
north
what does it even mean follow
the spine of soap tech mountains north
look at the back
on the top that's the map okay velocity
is there any kind of compass uh
no there is not okay one of the pins is
your north point
is there a way you can follow
okay i'll just tell you which way
this is north are you sure okay or
no this is this is north this is north
yes
north side right here okay yes okay good
have you found it
yes great
i know i just know yes google maps
google maps hasn't come out and
registered yet okay
turn the top sphere two inches clockwise
from the north pin so
keep an eye on our pin can you turn it
clockwise
okay okay uh
then push in that north pin
[Music]
maybe turn it more until it stops it's
not stopping
oh wait oh i think i almost got it gotta
feel out the give
oh
i'm gonna break it oh oh oh okay i got
it
so we begin your journey
okay once the first pin is in
turn it counterclockwise
until it stops
okay okay now from the pins
north follow the pin uh
counter-clockwise to the next pin
so the next pin counter-clockwise would
be the south pin
so there's well there's three pins
uh south uh southwest pin okay
push it in bam yes now
if you can catch where the next step is
going where
i've already turned it now you're going
clockwise
until it stops okay i think i got it
yeah okay now press down the third pin
yes now anti-clockwise that
makes sense i don't know why those
directions say that
counterclockwise once more yeah
baby you got a locked sphere
[Music]
okay well if i keep turning it yeah
there we go it is closed
and there you go all right and that was
everything that was in the
total war warhammer 2 surfing guy
edition
um there were supposed to be a set of
stickers here somewhere
but they were not sent in this one this
was a factory sample so it will probably
be in the one that you get
and that'll pretty much do it for more
unboxings you can subscribe to the
gamespot youtube channel
and see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you